ten degrees left thingies in one piece
[Music]
play your back over ADT that's great you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a weird way to
thank me for saving your life buddy but
you're welcome kindness
[Music]
stop shooting Allen that was my bad
California Highway Patrol ass boy
helping that armored car job you think
some of their own were involved I want
you to go on the inside calling the
cover within the department that's
awesome you're gonna be with a rookie
named John Baker you're gonna be francis
llewellyn poncherello
it's a fucked-up name are the first two
female names John none of these scores
meet even the lowest standards you've
had 23 surgeries I feel pretty darn good
I'm on a pharmaceutical regiment that
helps a lot really hind that you can
ride a motorcycle I'll give you that yes
ma'am
like a [ __ ] I like you thank you
you have nice eyes thank you what's up
I'm John poncherello awesome man we're
partners pretty badass you suited up for
battle looking like UPS drivers yeah
this job is crucial for saving my
marriage what are you wearing my uniform
I thought you'd probably wanna see what
I look like in all brown it's great John
it's like you're three beers too
intimate almost of motorcycle cop I got
no emotion there's a job find at 5:30
cops
these bikes will never catch those
great donut that opens on the booth when
I better got to stop are you guys
talking [ __ ] I mean things you said they
like to bike to see was pointing at my
dick I feel like it I hurt but key no I
think is small I said he looks so buff
that you make the up bike so tiny
oh I hope that you're not preying on
girls with low self-esteem
how are you judging them like by by
their hair like how straight their teeth
are yeah that's really shallow
real talk she ate my lunch she ate your
ass everyone's eating everyone's ass now
what about hygiene if you go to the
bathroom and you see some baby wipes
Greenlight's 24 hours solve this case
for you five there's no way to track
this guy why don't you scan his face we
don't have a [ __ ] bat computer right
Google you've been carrying me over that
baths Oh drag you there but I'm not
gonna cradle you like a new wife saved
your life I knew you're gonna bring that
up just get it over with
did you faceplant into my pubic Mound no
no that could have swore I felt your
nose or your lips you might be in like a
little bit of contact when you get
intimate with these gals his oral
expected like I ain't with the butt oh
yeah that's standard boss that's
standard Wow things have changed
[Music]
you